اود ان اقول واصحح انني لم استخدم مطلقا
طائره تابعه لبن علي هذا لم يحصل ابدا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى هذه الحلقه
الجديده من الذاكره السياسيه ضمن سلسله
السياسيه والوزيره الفرنسيه السابقه ميشيل
اليومري فاهلا بك معنا مجددا معالي
الوزيره على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
بالقذافي وليس فقط الاطاحه به انما التخلص
منه شخصيا لانه يعرف ويملك الكثير من
الملفات بخصوص تمويل حملاته الانتخابيه في
الداخل الفرنسي
الى اتخاذ قرار التدخل وكان الذي يتواصل
مع السياسيين كما مع الراي العام الفرنسي
من اجل اقناعهم لانه هناك مذبحه ست في
ليبيا ويجب عليه التدخل بحسب ما اتذكر من
تلك الفتره ان هذا التدخل لم يكن علي في
شان موضوعا بهذا الحجم وبهذه الصوره
المباشره وبهذه الفاعليه ذلك التدخل كان
قويا وكان من الصعب امام كل الذين يعرفون
بصوره جيده ليبيا وتقاليد المعارضه بين
مدينتي برقا وطرابلس اي يقوم بسماع صوت
اخر
مغلفه دائما بالنوايا الحسنه فقط قد يكون
هناك نوايا حسنا لمساعده الشعوب الاخرى
ولكن هناك اتهامات شخصيه فيها تحقيقات
قضائيه كبرى على في داخل الفرنسي ضد
الرئيس ساكوزي بتلقي اموال من زعيم دوله
اجنبيه ولذلك اراد التخلص منه ما كان
موقفك شخصيا من ذلك
بيقوم مورنجه كهذه ولكن ما اقوله ان
العداله الفرنسيه تنظر في هذه القضيه
ولننتظر ما ستقوله في هذه القضيه بالنظر
الى مختلف الشهود ومختلف القضاه الذين
احيانا ما يناقضون بعضهم ليست لدي معلومات
كافيه لكي ادلي براي في هذه النقطه لم اكن
مطلعه على هذا الملف ولا اعتقد انه يعود
لي ان اقول ان كان هذا صحيحا ام لاحيا لا
شيء اجهله
الحكومي مباشره
[موسيقى]
وبحسب التقاليد يجب عدم التحدث عن قضيه
القيد النظر امام القضاء وما اقوله مبدئيا
هو ان هناك شهودا لا يدلون باقوال في
الاتجاه ذاته وهناك افادات نيكولا ساكوزي
التي يجب اخذها في الاعتبار وبما ان
القضيه لا تزال عالقه امام القضاء سننتظر
الحكم
جدا
ونقدر وضعك ولكن بالمعنى السياسي يقال انه
ساركوزي وفرنسا كانت تمضي وراء الركب
الامريكي وتنفذ سياسه القياده من الخلف
التي تخدم الولايات المتحده اي ان
الولايات المتحده تقود من الخلف وفرنسا
واوروبا تتصدر المشهد في شان الليبي الى
اي ماده باعتقاد كانت فرنسا تنفذ رغبات
امريكيه في ما يتعلق بليبيا
شغل ليبي
بالسكر
ما اذكر كانت هناك ثلاثه بلدان تريد ان
تتدخل بصوره سريعه وهي فعل ذلك حتى قبل
الامريكيين وهذه الدول هي فرنسا وبريطانيا
وقطر في مرحله ثانيه تدخلت الولايات
المتحده والامارات العربيه هذه هي البلدان
التي تدخلت في ليبيا وقتها وبحسب ما اذكر
لا اعتقد ابدا ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قد تلعبت بالموقف الفرنسيه سبق
ان ذكرته
هو الذي كان المبادئ في هذا المجال على
المستوى الفرنسي حتى يكون هناك تدخل
لا يردد دائما ان الوزير ينفذ القرارات
على المستوى الدولي والعسكري هذه الامور
كلها هي من صلاحيات رئيس الجمهوريه والا
فهذا الوزير يستقيل
الانفتاح على الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
في الكثير من البلدان هذه التقاليد موجوده
وزير الدفاع او وزير الخارجيه ينفذ قرارات
رئيس الدوله في فرنسا رئيس الدوله هو
القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
رئاسي ان يعني العلاقه مع الرئيس والرئيس
هو الذي يقرر ربما الاخرى رؤساء حكمات هم
الذين يقررون همم في همم موضوع سوريا الان
لماذا قررت فرنسا الانفتاح في فتره ما
ايام الرئيس الروسي ايضا على الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد رغم كل همات التي سقط
ضده في مجال حقوق الانسان وهذا موضوع حساس
جدا بالنسبه الى فرنسا
قدمت مكاسبه لكل اوروبا والعالم وكانت
نموذجا حتى خارج اوروبا ان تمسكنا بحقوق
الانسان راسخ ولكن السياسه الخارجيه يجب
ان تكون برغماتيه وان تعاملنا فقط مع
الدول التي لديها ذات نظره الى حقوق
الانسان لا يكون لدينا علاقات مع بلدان
كثيره في العالم هناك بلدان حتى داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي نرى ان ممارستها
السياسيه هي محطه جدلا وشك في ما يتعلق
بتطبيق حقوق الانسان اذا هذه مساله معقده
بالنسبه الى سوريا هنا اتذكر جيدا تلك
المرحله علينا ان نعلم
كانت لديه التحفظ شاطئ ذاتها التي كانت
لدى شغاك حيل بشار الاسد ايام جاك شيراك
كانت العلاقات صعبه تحسنت ما حافظ الاسد
ولكن بعد ذلك شعرنا ان بشار الاسد لا يفي
بالتزاماته حدث بعض التشنج بين بشار الاسد
وفرنسا وكذلك بين الاسد وبلدان الاخرى مثل
دول الخليج كان لدي ساكوزي مشروع كبير تحت
عنوان الاتحاد من اجل المتوسط من اجل
تحقيقه كان عليه ان يضم اليه كل البلدان
المعنيه
عن هذا الاتحاد حاول ساقوزي اي يعاود
الاتصال مع بشار الاسد لينجز مشروع
الاتحاد من اجل المتوسط بعد ذلك راينا ان
هناك بعض الالتزامات التي لم يتم الايفاء
بها لاحقا وبعد الربيع العربي ايضا راينا
كيف تعامل بشار الاسد مع معارضه وهنا
تدهورت العلاقات صدرت مواقف فرنسيه معارضه
ضد الرئيس السوري
في ثورته
من الاوقات واذا اردنا ان نتحدث في هذا
الموضوع وهذا ما نراه اليوم في روسيا هذا
الامر يطرح الكثير من المشكلات بالنسبه
الى خذلان الشعب السوري ساخزي لم ينجح في
البدايه مع بشار الاسد لاجباره على اتخاذ
موقف مختلفا اذا ما طالب شعبه ولا اعتقد
ان فرنسا كانت الدوله الوحيده التي حاولت
مع الاسد فالسلطات السعوديه على ما اعتقد
حاولت افهمه ان بعض الامور لا يمكن ان
تحدث وعليه الاستماع الى مطالب الشعب
عندما يكون المرء على راس الدوله
العسكريه في سوريا همم ما الذي جعله يعرض
عن ذلك لاحقا هل هو الانسحاب الامريكي
الرفض الاميركي للتدخل رغم الخطوط الحمراء
التي حددت ان ذات
جوبنسكي علاقه
لم اكن اتابع فيها هذه الامور لانني كنت
وقتها في البرلمان الاوروبي ومهتمه اكثر
بالقضايا الاوروبيه اعتقد انه حدثت وقتها
نقاشات بين دول عند ومنها بين فرنسا
والولايات المتحده لمعرفه ما هو الموقف
الواجب اتخذه في المنطقه السوريه ولكنها
لم تكون فقط محصوره للمنطقه السوريه لان
الازمه السوريه كانت لها تبيعات ابعد من
ذلك واننا نلاحظ اليوم ان القوه العظمى
مهتمه بما يحدث في هذه اللعبه الاقليميه
في هذه النقطه تحديدا اكرر وانا لم اكن في
الحكومه اذا لا يمكنني ان اؤكد تفاصيل تلك
المرحله ولكن اعتقد انه كان هناك نوع من
التقارب في بعض المواقف وتباين بسيط في
البعض الاخر كان هناك توافق مبدئيا على
ادانه ممارسات بشار الاسد ولكن لا احب ان
اتكلم عن شيء في وقت لم اكن فيه في صلب
موقع اتخاذ القرار وقتها
في هذه الحلقه مع للوزيره شكرا جزيلا
لوجودك معنا مشاهدينا الكرام فاصل قصير
قبل ان نتابع ما لدينا في هذه الحلقه مع
من شلال يوماري السياسيه والوزيره
الفرنسيه السابقه
الصور التي اظهرها الامريكيون واعتقد كان
لديهم غيرها كان بالامكان ان تظهر وكانها
من اطلاق الصواريخ والصور التي لدينا
والماخوذه من زاويه اخرى اظهرت انها تتعلق
بمنشاه مدنيه
[موسيقى]
الكرام اينما كنتم نتابع واياكم هذه
الحلقه من الذاكره السياسيه مع ميشيل اليو
ماريا السياسيه والوزيره الفرنسيه السابقه
اهلا بك معنا مجددا مع الوزيره الجزائر في
اكتوبر عام 2010 بصفتك وزيره للعدل
وشبهت العلاقه بين فرنسا والجزائر بعلاقه
زوجين ما الذي جعل كل الفتره الماضيه ما
بعد استقلال الجزائر هذه العلاقه في شد
وجذب صعودا وهبوطا
وهبوط في هذه العلاقه كما بين زوجين ولهذا
شبهات العلاقه بعلاقه بين شريكين هناك
الكثير من النقاط المشتركه بين البلدين
والكثير من المصالح المشتركه ايضا لقد
تسنى لي ان اقول ذلك للرئيس بوتفليقه هناك
كل المشكلات المتعلقه بمك الارهاب وتهريب
المخدرات في فرنسا لدينا جليه من اصول
جزائريه مهمه جدا لدينا الكثير من الشباب
الذين يحملون الجنسيتين الفرنسيه
والجزائريه في كل مره ازور الجزائر احاول
ان التقي اياها هؤلاء الشباب كل هذه
الامور تدفعنا للعمل معا احيانا نقوم بذلك
ولكن احيانا اخرى لدينا تاريخ ومصالح ربما
تكون غير متقاربه قد تؤدي الى توترات
اتذكروا زياره الاولى لرئيس الجزائري كانت
قبل العام 2010 بدانا بالكلام عن حرب
الجزائر
وحتى نهايه الحرب الجزائريه كان عمري 14
عاما وتاليا انا لا اتذكرها وهذه من
الماضي ماذا علينا ان نفعل الان هل نبقى
في الماضي ام نتحدث عن شهدتي تحديات
المستقبل وهذا اللقاء الذي كان من المقرر
ان يمتد الى ثلاثه ارباع الساعه امتد الى
نحو خمس ساعات حيث جلسنا الى مائده الغذاء
ودعو وزراء واعتقد اننا نجحنا في اقامه
علاقه قائمه على الثقه مع نظراء الذين
تعاقبوا وهو ما سهل تحقيق الكثير من
الامور في مجال مكافحه المخدرات اذكر انني
نظمت لقاءات بعيده عن الاعلام وهو ما
ساعدنا على ان نقوم بامور مشتركه مع بعضنا
وهناك ايضا مشروع الاتحاد من اجل المتوسط
حاولت ان اقنعه وان اشرح هذه الفكره في
بعض الموضوعات التي لدينا وجوهات نظر
مختلفه فيها مع جزائر ولكن نحاول دائما ان
نقوم بخطوات من اجل احراز تقدم ومن اجل
خدمه مواطنين قبل اي ولكن الجزائر دائما
مطالبه فرنسا بالاعتذار عن حقبه الاستعمار
عن المجازر التي ارتكبتها القوه الفرنسيه
في الداخل الجزائري لماذا من الصعب على
فرنسا الدوله وليس الاشخاص الذين لم
يعيشوا ربما في كثير منهم تلك الحرب لماذا
من الصعب عليها ان تتفهم حاجه اخر ايضا
وفرنسا هي فرنسا الحريه والمساواه والاخاء
ان تتفهم ان للاخر ايضا حاجات ورغبات
ودوافع للتحرر من ارث الماضي الثقيل جدا
عليهم
تفهم ذلك جيدا ولا سيما ان تاريخ فرنسا هو
تاريخ اليمه ولن اعود الى الاستعمار
الروماني واعتقد ان الرؤساء المتعاقدين
منذ جاك شيراك والرئيس الحالي ايمانويل
كتابه تاريخ المشترك وهذه افضل طريقه من
لتقاسمي هذا التاريخ نحن نعيش في عالم
خطير جدا يرتفع فيه منسوب التوتر وتاليا
ان مسؤوليه كل دوله هي ان تحضر للمستقبل
حتى يكون هذا المستقبل امنا ومريحا
لمواطنيها وهذا الامر يتحقق من خلال العمل
المشترك بين الدول والمواطنين وانا تحدثت
عن هذا الموضوع قبل قليل وكنت في كل مره
اطلب من السفير تنظيم لقاء لي مع شباب او
الطلاب الجامعيين او الفنانين في كل مره
كنت اشعر بالدهشه لانهم كانوا مهتمين بشكل
اساسي بتنميه العلاقات وكيف كنا نحن
الفرنسيين نستطيع ان نساعدهم من اجل
استخدام مواهبهم في هذا المجال
اذا الموضوع لرمزيته يعني بين قوسين عدم
الاعتذار لرمزيه الامر لخطورته على
الكبرياء الفرنسي او لانه يحمل فرنسا
طبيعات قانونيه وماليه ربما
هناك دائما مجموعات تطالب دائما فرنسا
بدفع تعويضات للجزائر ولكن هذا الامر
يتطلب اعاده درس كل شيء في شكل كامل وفي
هذا الاطار قدم الرئيس اقتراحا وعلينا ان
ننتظر نتائج ذلك بالنسبه الى الماضي هو
الماضي من الطبيعي ان نقوم بتحليل هذا
التاريخ بصوره مشتركه حتى نتفادى تكرار
الامور السلبيه التي حدثت في الماضي وهذا
ربما هو دور المؤرخين القادرين على
التفريق بين الصح والخطا وما ينبغي تفسيره
في هذه الصيغه او تلك اما دور المسؤولين
في الدوله فهو يتمثل في العمل ازاء
الاوضاع الدوليه الخطيره والوطنيه الصعبه
حيث نرى تصاعد اشكال العنف وسوء الفهم
بدفع احيانا من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعيه
وهو عنصر مهم جدا على المستوى السياسي
اعتقد ان دور المسؤولين السياسيين وربما
قبل كل شيء يتمثلوا في الانكباب على
الحاضر والمستقبل
تاريخ جيدا جدا ان فرنسا عارضت بشده الحرب
على العراق عام 2003 ولكنه سيذكر ايضا
انها شاركت وبقوه في حرب افغانستان في عام
2000 و 2001 ما كان الفرق في التعاطي
الفرنسي بين الموضوعين لماذا قبلت هنا
ورفضت هنا
ايه ده بس لا بقى
بالنسبه الى افغانستان حدث ذلك عقب احداث
11 من سبتمبر في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حيث كانت القاعده تتخذ من
افغانستان ملاذان لها وكان هناك نظام
طالبان الذي كان يقمع خصوصا النساء كذلك
شاهدنا كيف دمرت طالبان التماثيل الكبرى
في افغانستان التي تنتمي الى تراث العالمي
المشترك وحقوق الانسان كانت منتهكه في
افغانستان
محرومات من حق التعليم وبما انه تم
استهداف الولايات المتحده مباشره من خلال
احداث الحاديه عشر من سبتمبر والمشاهد
التي شهدناها ولا سيما منهار البرجين في
نيويورك وعليها ان تدخل فرنسا
وصديق ساعدنا حربنا ضد النازيه في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لذلك تدخلنا في
افغانستان هذا الامر تم في اطار الحلف
الاطلسي وهذا الامر لا ينبغي اغفاله شاركت
في حرب افغانستان بلدان من الناتو واخرى
من خارج هذا الحلف هذا الامر مهم وتجدر
الاشاره اليه اما بالنسبه الى العراق
فالوضع مختلف كان هناك عمل وقائي بطرق غير
مقبوله بالنسبه الينا ساسرد لك طرفه لكنها
ذات مغزى في مطلع الفتره التي تسلم فيها
وزاره الدفاع التقينا في اجتماع فبراج او
وارسو لم اعد اذكر بالضبط اين مع دونالدز
فيلد الذي كان نظير الامريكي الذي اراد
وقتها ان يقنع الاوروبيين بالمشاركه في
العمليه المنوي تنفيذها في العراق
ميسي
عدد من الصور الملتقى بواسطه الاقمار
الصناعيه وعرضها علينا حيث لم يكن هناك
الا وزراء حول الطاوله وقدمت تلك الصور
على انها من الصوت لاطلاق الصواريخ وقال
ان صدام حسين سيستخدم هذه المنصات لاطلاق
الصواريخ وكانت وصلتني اصداء عما ينوي
قوله وعرضه علينا قبل ايام من الاجتماع
فطلبت من الجيش الفرنسي انطلاقا من
اقمارنا الصناعيه التي اكبر عدد ممكن من
الصور للعراق
مضحكه
عندما عارض رامز في صوره اخرجت الصور التي
التقطتها الاقمار الصناعيه الفرنسيه التي
اظهرت انها تتعلق بصوامع القمح فقدت
الزاويه التي تم من خلالها التقاط الصور
لم تكن نفسها الصور التي اظهرها
الامريكيون واعتقد كان لديهم غيرها كان
بالامكان ان تظهر وكانها من الساتون
لاطلاق الصواريخ وصور التي لدينا
والماخوذه من زاويه اخرى اظهرت انها تتعلق
بمنشاه مدنيه
السياده لو لم يكن لدينا الا الصور
الامريكيه لربما كنا اعتمدنا التفسير ذاته
ولكننا لم نفعل ذلك هذا كان الموقف
الفرنسيه
يكون الامر مشروعا عندما نشارك في عمليه
عسكريه مع دوله حليفه وصديقه تعرضت لهجوم
اما في وضع اخر لنشاركه معها عندما نجد
خطا
وجكشراك ارتقى ان هناك خطا واننا سنخلق
منطقه توتر ونزاع واسعه في تلك المنطقه
اذا قمنا بتقويض العراق وكان بامكاننا
انتقاد صدام حسين ولذلك اتخذنا هذا الموقف
انا ذهبت وشرحت هذا الموقف في كل دول
الخليج وقتها كمفده من الرئيس جاك شغارك
ان نتوقف عند هذا الحد في هذه الحلقه فقط
ولكن على انه متابع في بدايه الحلقه
المقبله معك شكرا جزيلا لوجودك معنا في
هذه الحلقات على شاشه العربيه مشاهدينا
الكرام نتابع واياكم مع السياسيه والوزيره
الفرنسيه السابقه ميشيل اليو ماري في
بدايه الحلقه المقبله في الموعد نفسه فارج
تتفضلوا بالبقاء معنا
متفقا تماما مع الحريري عندما سعى الاخير
الى استعاده سياده لبنان الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه من سوريا وكان شراك مقتنعا منذ
البدايه ان اغتيال الحريري كان من تدبير
حزب الله ومن خلفه سوريا شراك تاثر شخصيا
لانه فقد صديقا وكان غاضبا جدا مما حدث
ومن الناحيه السياسيه هذا كان عنصر زعزعه
في هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]